j'ai dû appeler pour organiser une conférence téléphonique.
Et quand j'ai changé de bureau,
nous n'avions pas de meuble au début
donc nous avons installé le téléphone sur une poubelle.
Une chose qui m'a surpris, lors de mon emménagement à Washington,
était à quel point le gouvernement comptait encore sur le papier.
Ceci est un bureau à Winston-Salem,
Caroline du Nord,
où les gens avaient peur
que l'immeuble soit peut-être structurellement trop faible
pour le poids de tout ce papier.
Oui...
Le papier a ses mauvais côtés.
Voilà un quizz :
si votre nom commence par une lettre entre H et Z,
entre H et Z, pourriez-vous lever la main ?
Waouh.
J'ai une mauvaise nouvelle :
votre historique militaire a peut-être été détruit lors d'un incendie en 1973.
(Rires)
Oui...
L'administratif papier est aussi plus lent et plus sujet aux erreurs.
Si vous êtes un vétéran
et que vous postulez pour votre couverture médicale
en utilisant un formulaire papier,
vous pourriez attendre quelques mois pour que ce formulaire soit étudié.
Nous avons remplacé cela par un formulaire sur internet
et à présent, la plupart des vétérans vérifient
s'ils peuvent avoir accès à leur couverture médicale
en 10 minutes.
(Applaudissements)
Voici un autre projet dont je suis fier.
Nous avons travaillé pour le service pour les PME
pour migrer l'un de leurs systèmes du papier au numérique.
Ceci est une photo d'avant
et celle-ci d'après.
Même bureaux, même personnes,
juste un meilleur système pour tout le monde.
A un moment, nous voulions célébrer la modernisation d'un système,
nous sommes allés à une épicerie,
nous avons demandé : « Pouvez-vous faire un gâteau
décoré avec le formulaire que nous avons digitalisé ? »
Et les employés de l'épicerie ont été très surpris par cette demande.
Ils voulaient une lettre sur papier à en-tête du gouvernement.
Travaillant pour le gouvernement, nous avons écrit une lettre :
« Vous pouvez utiliser ce formulaire du domaine public
sur un gâteau pour raison de célébration. »
(Rires)
Ce qui a inspiré des blagues sur remplir le formulaire
sur un gâteau à trois étages - on sait rire là-bas.
J'ai beaucoup parlé de papier,
mais nous avons aussi abordé les systèmes en panne.
Nous apportons des pratiques informatiques
comme le design orienté utilisateur et le cloud,
et nous avons aussi aidé à améliorer les achats.
Il se trouve que le gouvernement achète des logiciels
de la même façon qu'il achète des chaises, des brownies et des tanks :
en suivant les règles du gouvernement qui font plus de 1 000 pages.
Donc oui, il y a certaines choses folles au gouvernement actuellement.
Mais si vous pensez que la Silicon Valley est le sauveur de l'histoire,
(Rit)
attendez d'entendre la suite.
Certains esprits les plus brillants dans la technologie
travaillent pour des start-ups de livraison de repas et de scooters
et comment mieux livrer de la marijuana aux gens.
Est-ce la chose la plus importante sur laquelle travailler maintenant ?
La Silicon Valley aime parler de rendre le monde meilleur.
Mais vous ressentez l'impact que vous avez encore plus profondément
au gouvernement.
C'est quelqu'un qui a perdu son père.
Il m'a traqué sur Twitter
pour me dire qu'un des systèmes que nous avions améliorés
avait bien marché pour lui pendant un moment difficile.
C'est dans ces durs moments que le gouvernement doit fonctionner
et c'est pourquoi il faut de l'innovation au gouvernement.
Bon, je dois vous avouer un truc.
Quand je suis arrivé à Washington,
j'utilisais des termes comme « bureaucrate ».
Maintenant,
je suis plus enclin à utiliser des termes comme « fonctionnaire ».
Comme Francine, qui peut vous faire pleurer.
Ou du moins, elle m'a fait pleurer.
Parce qu'elle est si inspirante.
Je suis aussi profondément, férocement fier de mes collègues.
Ils travaillent sur des situations illogiques
et restent tard la nuit pour arriver au bon résultat.
Le gouvernement ne peut pas payer d'énormes primes,
donc nous avons fini par créer nos propres récompenses.
Notre mascotte est un crabe nommé Molly.
Et donc, cette récompense est en fait un sac en forme de crabe,
visé dans de la tôle.
De nos jours, je crois moins aux solutions miracles
qui vont tout arranger.
Je crois davantage
dans les gens qui répondent présent pour aider.
Si vous cherchez quelque chose de profondément rempli de sens --
et sans rien vous cacher, parfois incroyablement frustrant --
voici ce que vous avez besoin de savoir.
Il existe quelque chose de difficile,
désordonné, vital et magique en train d'arriver
quand les fonctionnaires s'associent aux technologues
à l'échelle municipale, régionale et nationale.
Vous n'avez pas à le faire pour toujours.
Mais vous pouvez faire la différence dans le service public
maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)